okay Donald Trump's latest non mask
visit to a PPE factory has led to an
entire day's production of medical swabs
being thrown in the trash destroyed this
was on a trip to Maine that Trump did a
few days ago he went to Bangor Maine
Guilford Maine maybe one other spot the
company he visited is called Puritan
medical products and among other things
they make sterile cotton swabs or
Schwab's as Trump once referred to them
these are sterile meaning workers wear
lab coats hair nets plastic booties over
their shoes all of that stuff in walks
Trump with no masks walks around talks
to people we're showing our audience
that's watching TV footage of Trump
walking around getting closer to
everybody than the recommended six feet
and this of course raised a bunch of
questions hey this is supposed to be a
sterile environment and the marketing
manager had to admit that indeed swabs
produced during this time meaning when
Trump was there will be discarded in
their defense or or or I guess in
Trump's defense they were only planning
a limited production run that day in
light I guess of Trump's presence there
Puritan is one of only two factories in
the entire country that makes these
swabs there are still shortages in some
areas even in Maine one third of nursing
homes were out of swabs last month
60% of Maine nursing homes had seven or
fewer individual swabs on hand so an
entire day's production of swabs in the
trash because Donald Trump who had to
walk around with that doofus see
expression on his face uncovered by a
mask so in the end maybe the real
tragedy is not they threw out all of
that day's swabs maybe the real tragedy
is that while facing swab shortages the
entire factory mostly shut down because
Trump was coming to visit and they
produced very little to begin with
instead of having a full and real
production day of swabs to get swabs to
people who need them but once again I
have to ask why did the factor
allowed Trump to go in without a mask
and without booties on his shoes I get
it he's the president but at some point
this has to stop right like I would love
to see a company just fully insist it
doesn't matter if it's the president
you're not coming in without a mask
period no exception end of story don't
try to bully us just either wear the
mask or go somewhere else but at the
same time I do get it because there's
perceived prestige associated with a
sitting president coming to tour your
facility in rural Maine people will let
him do whatever he wants which is the
story of his life and they did here I
mean remember grab him by the
you-know-what that's a story about Trump
gets whatever he wants Trump not wearing
masks when he goes to places even when
the production floor is supposedly
sterile that's another example of Trump
gets whatever he wants that's the story
of his life and maybe someday a factory
or some business or someone will say
it's not happening my friend it is not
happening we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today we are going to talk about
how the average American views police
after the last ten days of protests how
is public opinion about police shifted
in the last 10 days number two South
Korea and North Korea are no longer
talking and geopolitics experts are
worried about what this might a signal
for the future
and lastly Donald Trump is planning to
re-establish those massive campaign
rallies in the next two weeks
potentially making them super spreader
events of coronavirus we will talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com and
of course remember if you prefer to
consume the show in long-form audio
format instead of clips on YouTube if
that's where you're watching right now
we have a free daily audio podcast this
the free audio podcast it is on iTunes
it's on Google podcasts it's on Spotify
it's on Pandora it's on stitcher
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
you can find the david pakman show
podcast get it but then become a member
and we'll see you on the bonus show
momentarily